square was born in st
louis missouri of all places founded by
jack dorsey
there are some other people involved but
he was the principal st louis missouri
in 2009
and during that time as the history goes
they were coming
in to introduce a simple financial
product
it was the square reader remember a
little reader that folks could plug in
to their phone
like a limo driver or independent
business people consultants
swipe a credit card and trade money for
a transaction with you and me
maybe you're buying baseball cards from
them maybe they're a simple entrepreneur
maybe they're at the county fair selling
t-shirts it allowed
the point of sale to be in the palm of
their hand anywhere
and everywhere so they started there
where'd they get their money well it was
traditional venture capital
they had a series a about 10 million
dollars in november of 09
from coastal ventures a premier uh very
environmentally focused
venture capital firm but also with a lot
of uh finance and security investments
then a 27 million series b remember abc
that's the order of which you raise
venture capital they came from sequoia
january of 11.
so so far everything's going along
pretty typically
and then suddenly they pop a hundred
million dollar series c in july of 11
led by kleiner perkins now you got
kleiner sequoia cosa and jack dorsey
we all knew this was going to be
something it was going to be something
big
because these are the biggest of the vcs
are now putting nine
digits in play they move forward and
in 2012 a
series d of 200 million from a cast
of investors so now you really have seen
the company the company is often running
and it's moving and you've got the the
cash app has been introduced and you
also have the square reader
so now they're looking at well basically
you're just a credit card processor and
you're taking a percentage that was kind
of what paypal did
they allowed you to buy things on the
internet and they took a percent well
there was more to it
and as you'll see jack dorsey was
investing and
acquiring companies as a matter of fact
over the course of square
from 2009 to date they have actually
acquired
19 different companies culminating in
the 2020 i think it was
50 million wasn't it paul they paid for
credit karma
50 million that's right so now you've
got credit karma acquired with square
you're opening up a pallet of small
business and consumer and when i say
consumer
consumers like you and me that operate
small businesses so you have
smbs like formal businesses with the
storefront and things like that
offering retail services the familiar
square point of sale
and also the ability to spin it around
you add a tip sign your name
with your finger i mean really slick
system but in addition
you still have mobility as i said limo
drivers people that have remote
businesses
matter of fact over the weekend the biz
doc babe and i went and saw
some wonderful stevie rayvon cover band
here in texas
and they were selling t-shirts for their
band and the woman there that
represented the band
she had a square reader and she had a
square
signature tab so it was really really
kind of cool to still see that going on
knowing i was going to do the case study
now
the point is that's where it started but
with these acquisitions
a lot more happened so here you go they
start cash app
in 2013. that was a big deal that's
where people like you and me could trade
cash with one another
not just have to do almost like a credit
card retail transaction
i could lend you a hundred dollars then
they announced square capital in 2014
and then an interesting thing happened
between 13 and 14.
see these here this is the revenue
numbers now i'm going to take a pause
right now and run through the revenue
numbers real quick but they crossed half
a billion dollars
in revenue so that means they're
suddenly doing 40 million
dollars a month which is over
a million dollars a day so suddenly this
is a very very
real company uh and if anybody doubted
its ability to get uh trajectory and
altitude and financial services industry
where everything is spelled with a
billion not million
financial services it's all about the
billions not the millions
so all of a sudden they're at 850
and they actually cross the magic
billion mark halfway between 14 and 15
and then toward the end of 15 no
surprise november
of 2015 to have their ipo
now what's interesting if you step back
here there's a little bit of controversy
around the ipo that i'll talk about
so when you're raising venture capital
they put a valuation on your company
that you mutually agree
sometimes you can look at comps or
comparatives of other companies that are
out there
sometimes you can't and it's what the
venture capitalists and you
wrestle to determine the valuation of
your company well when they did that 200
million dollar series d
they had a valuation of three billion
dollars so they are in the unicorn club
three times three billion dollars they
then raised about 100 million in debt in
early 14 i think it was and then
in october of 14 they raised 150 million
in a series e
now there's an interesting thing here
why would you raise a hundred million
dollars in debt well else it all has to
do with dilution
because that was a six billion dollar
valuation when they raised the last 150
million in the series e
which would be the last of the venture
funded phase for square
now why should you wait and raise that i
think there's a small lesson here
whenever you can extend the time from
one financing round to the other
and your business is on a good
trajectory you are decreasing the
percent of the business you're going to
give up in the next round
meaning your business will be more
valuable and if you let's say your
business is worth
300 million pick a big number and
somebody invests
100 million into it the 300 plus a 100
is 400 million
so therefore that 100 is 25
so that investor or the group of
investors would have 25
of it now you can roll this all the way
down to make it 3 million you took 1
million and they had 25
the same principles apply but the longer
you can wait when you're developing your
product and developing traction and
developing customers and developing
revenue
the better it is so that you give up a
less percent next time
and still people want to invest
especially if you're taking off
thanks for watching the short clip if
you like that and like to see the whole
episode
you can find it right here and for even
more
subscribe to this channel right here